[Music]
so
today is going to be a very interesting
session so gitlab as you may or may not
be aware
migrated from azure into gcp and the
goal of this session was a complete
honest session of
why they did it thoughts behind it the
pros the cons and really helped so that
you can understand what a real world
company does who has a lot of customers
when they're looking to do a migration
of this
sort and a lot of the considerations
that go into play
so first some quick housekeeping we have
something called the dory
so the dory is what's going to allow you
to ask questions and answers
throughout the event so feel free to log
into your app
you'll see right there where it says
dory q a and then you can ask questions
at the end we'll answer the questions as
well as you can come up to the mic
so we can dive a bit deeper so with that
being said let's get started
so first thing i'm just quickly going to
touch on is google cloud's migration
path and our methodology
so whenever you're doing a migration you
know whether it's on-prem to on-prem
on-prem to cloud cloud to cloud or
whatever the future's going to bring
you need to have a very methodol a
methodological approach right so the
idea of assessing what's in your
environment
anyone who's ever done this and tried
just moving something to the cloud often
breaks you know 20 other systems right
so it's very important
understanding technically what's there
the cost when you're going to move it
but also how all the things are
interconnected right because you want to
move things in the right order in the
right move groups
so you assess you understand what's
there the next step is setting up your
landing zone
right so what environment is it going to
look like when you come to google cloud
so that you can begin migrating right so
you set up things like your identity and
access management
security various policies connectivity
maybe back to a data center an
additional cloud
once that's all set up then you can do
the fun part which is actually migrating
and moving to the cloud
when you're in the cloud the next step
is optimizing because usually there's a
reason people move to the cloud and
there are a lot of
benefits around opera operationalizing
and taking it to the next level
so with that being said i'm going to
bring brandon up on stage
and he'll talk a bit about how gitlab
got there
thank you ted so much appreciated buddy
so uh today we're going to go through a
couple things
we are going to talk we'll talk a little
bit about our application
uh we're going to talk a bit about the
foundations and how we went through the
process
of moving over uh from azure to gcp we
go through migration
and we're going to have a little touch a
little on optimize that's
almost a secondary subject but we'll hit
this in a couple details so
a couple things my job here is to give
you a context of what gitlab is for a
very simple reason
gitlab.com or gitlab is a company we're
a single devops tool
so we cover everything from uh how you
go down how software developers write
software this is what they live in all
day long they go from the planning ideas
writing their software testing it for
quality ensuring that it has great
security
packaging up and deploying it in to
production and even eventually
monitoring it so this is what gitlab
does
what we're talking about today is
gitlab.com so there's two primary ways
that we think of a business
we have gitlab.com which is our sas
offering and that's what we're going to
spend most of today around
we also have git lab that most of our
customers the majority of our customers
still love to manage their own tool set
they run it in their vpc on-prem on gcp
and kubernetes all the above so those
are kind of the two different worlds
what we're going to do today
is walk through what the migration was
for us on our sas
platform so as we go through it on the
sas platform it's important to have some
context
on where we're going and what the
business drivers were for us
as a sas provider that said
here's some context for us as a company
so uh we've been incorporated
we're now about fifth year we have 500
employees
50 plus countries uh we are a fully
remote company so
there's not a single office in anywhere
of git lab you're going to get some
context as to
how that works we have very very broad
adoption so our business strategy
is a strategy called um user-based
open core so if you're interested in
this you can take a look search it on
google
search our ceo sid he talked through all
the different models that an open source
company has to consider and it is one of
the more challenging pieces to solve
and this is what we're trying to to get
to you get some really good context here
from the growth so
same in terms of what we're dealing with
from a growth standpoint we're now
pushing about 10 million repositories
running on gitlab.com
so big repositories as we made the move
some of what you need to understand with
gitlab is we also have a whole bunch of
other tool
pieces in here that matter so if we go
back to this and take a look at your
pipeline well we're now running
everyone's pipeline and that's a very
big use
case that's a lot of compute that
requires that you do it really well so
all of these as our comp as our customer
base grows is critical for us to do it
we obviously move pretty quickly we have
about 2 200 regular code contributors
we ship every month um and from that
standpoint we also have another 10
000 total contributors over the time
that have worked with us
now again this is a meta process so what
you're going to see is
we took gitlab as a tool that's where we
live that's what we breathe
gitlab is used as a migration tool to
migrate gitlab.com
so i'm going to give you a little
context of what gitlab is because you're
going to understand what we had to
optimize to in order to deliver it
so to that end uh the prerequisite slide
i'll just get a little context to this
this is just all the different
organizations that care well why does
that matter
because for us more and more of them are
running on a sas offering
more and more of them are looking in
either running or considering to run on
gitlab.com
it has to be mission critical we have to
deliver this perfect every time
but at the same point we use the exact
same code base
to run gitlab.com as we do ship to our
customers
and that's quite different so that
methodology is both a plus
but it also means that we have to me it
allows us to dog food the entire process
through
um our focus for our customers is you'll
see what we do
our customers like goldman sachs so
goldman spent for us
they moved over to get lab came on with
about a thousand
uh employees focused on really
optimizing changing the way they develop
they're obviously a good development
company if is anyone from goldman here
okay if you ask anyone for goldman like
they're a software company that is what
they do
uh when they tackled this initially they
said okay we'll go with a thousand users
we're gonna roll that out we'll get into
nine months to a year we'll let you know
when nine went to your hot goes
inside of a month they need another 5
000 licenses because they rolled it out
to everyone
so easy for them to roll it out we need
to make that sure that works really well
for gitlab.com as well right so that
process critical to
our business success couple things here
uh i'm releasing context these are our
core values
we believe deeply in the notion of
collaboration
as an open source company a couple
things here because i'm
more interested in showing you how this
works
when we say that we believe in
collaboration one of the important
things you want to know is
hey who do i need to work with well for
reference if you're interested in
gitlab.com we publish our entire entire
org chart
so you're going to know who you want to
work with how where
etc so in order to do that well
obviously
we need to be able to be uh very very
efficient and
we also of course will get into this a
little bit around the transparency now
the efficiency and cycle time
this is something that matters in what
we did and it matters to our customers
so both these are really critical in
being able to
build software quickly we've all heard
mark andreessen say software's eating
the world
got it the more interesting thing is his
most current point is cycle time
compression may be the most
underestimated force in determining who
are the winners and the losers in tech
this is the core of what a digital
transformation is and for us
we've got to do this because as you saw
while we're
a 500 person company that's wonderful
we're doing
great we enjoy it and today i'll be very
blunt microsoft's our biggest competitor
with that our superpower at gitlab is a
very simple thing we will iterate
faster than anyone if we can do that
well we succeed
if we don't we lose full stop and our
customers expect the same
um a couple other fun things here that
are always worth worth looking at
um on a transparency standpoint um
let me make sure we do this let's do
this it's always interesting to say
hey what's the roadmap look like so for
this standpoint if you're ever
interested
exactly on how we ship all of gitlab and
again get like a full tool
and end suite we publish our entire
roadmap
right we publish exactly when we're
going to go
where we're going to go what ships when
and it's full feedback so
regularly when we're looking at deciding
and prioritizing
anyone is anyone get lab customer okay
thank you awesome if you guys want to
prioritize where you want the next
feature
it's an issue it's open it works with
everyone in the world
and we obviously value that that's
something that allows us to move
moods much much faster one area here
that i'll probably look at
um we also look at transparency just as
a culture
so i'm going to give you this a little
bit this is a handbook any startups in
the room
okay anyone ever tried to deal with a
remote culture how do you manage remote
culture what are the right processes
this right here is a handbook that the
majority of yc
companies that want to go this is a
handbook it's 2000 pages
on everything how we run the company so
we literally write every single thing
down because we're 100 remote
decisions aren't made in a room they're
not made over a water cooler they're
made and start in an issue
we live in an issue we iterate an issue
and we move that quickly forward
so in this to give you a sense of just
sort of a little bit different than
maybe the world works
anyone been in the black art of
acquisitions
you probably haven't been if you have
been like
part of what my job is decided to maybe
take this a little bit different we
decided you know what would be great
why don't we go ahead and give everyone
an exact idea
of how we go through acquisitions
and we'll go through i can't drive this
as well backwards as i would like to
but um we go through and tell exactly
hey any company that would like to work
with us here's exactly how
we would work here's how your first days
would work here's how we value you
here's how we bring you in and so that
transparency is something that again
works across here
and the rest of the comfy so let me jump
back in
and click the next one because the
values are useful um
this is what we had to deal with but we
started as a company more or less in
this create space
so when we had to run our sas offering
we're only needing to deal with get
it's interesting it's really powerful
it's our core
but now as we've expanded and we deliver
this level of complexity
we have to be able to at a regular basis
be able to run that for every single
customer so that means we have to run
pipelines
it's going to mean that we have to have
a great managing we have to manage and
run all of this extremely well
so companies expect to be able to they
live in a silo
and when they come to get lab they're
asking hey how do i bring break down
those barriers how can i
run and develop concurrently instead of
sequentially
that was an issue for us it was a
surprise for us so as we went through
the process here
we used to of course have a bunch of
other tools too because we only started
in the git space
when we moved on to planning ci
monitoring we were surprised actually
ourselves when we put these things all
together exactly what the compression of
that cycle time was
which is wonderful but when we run that
product now as a sas for every customer
that thing better run
perfectly every time because they are
betting our customers are betting their
business on gitlab.com
as the ability to ship product every
single day
so that's the part that we had to make
sure we executed perfectly
one other thing we talked a bit about
transparency which
obviously matters but i'm gonna you're
gonna see a theme here uh throughout
that's fine um i'm gonna move to the
next side here
real quickly um give a little context of
what we had to migrate over so
when we moved over we had to move
everything from
the source code but we had to move all
the kanban boards we had to move our
project management
likewise we wanted to roll out when we
made this we want to make it easy to do
things like if you look right in the
middle review apps
we want to make it easy for our
customers to be able to deploy new apps
exactly how it's running instantaneously
and so that was uh that was the the last
part we did there
that said i'm going to quickly get it
over to andrew because you guys want to
know why we moved over
um we're going to spend most of our time
some people will know gitlab is the
left-hand side here
as an end user that's mostly what the ui
ux is today the rest of it we're going
to spend on
this part how do we migrate all the
different pieces of the complex
application
that is is gitlab a couple couple really
important things that we focused on
um first off we wanted to be suitable
obviously for mission critical that's
really important for us to grow our
business uh we needed performance we
needed consistency and price
that was the reason we moved from
microsoft we saw
better performance we'll highlight that
better consistency and significantly
better
price the other part if you're thinking
about the other part was culture so
more and more development is landing and
cloud native you're here you've heard
this all day
you heard anthos i don't have to explain
any of that
however for us when we want to work with
a partner that's going to help us
understand and work deeply around those
technologies there's not a better place
for us to go than was google
and so that was part of why we moved um
last one was um and that hit on part two
and part three so part three
a lot of those are technologies that
while we use them very deeply
the advantage of us for us as a company
worked with google early was we have
real deep insight into how that works
uh likewise google uniquely was willing
to walk us through exactly how google
developers develop so we get a
kind of a future look into perhaps how
other large companies or
probably the fastest one of the fastest
shifting companies in the world actually
do their devops lifecycle
that said um last one i'm going to turn
over to
uh andrew here in a second and last one
i think speaks pretty much for itself
we're a small company in doing so we're
gonna write all up about it
andrew's gonna tell you how we did it
and um i think that's pretty helpful for
us so with that i'm like andrew
chat this is probably who you want to
talk to and much appreciated
thanks thanks brandon um my name is
[Laughter]
my name is andre nitigates i'm an
engineer at kit lab
i helped lead the team that moved
gitlab.com from
azure to gcp um now brandon told you
a little bit about why we wanted to move
to gcp and i'm going to tell you a
little bit about how we did it and i
need a clicker
cool so the goal of the project was
really really simple
is basically move gitlab.com to gcp so
we could state it really simply
the problem was how could we go about
doing this
now brandon discussed our company values
earlier i'm going to try
illustrate how we use these company
values uh to apply them to the way that
we work and in particular i'm going to
focus on
efficiency or how we love boring
solutions
iteration or how we focus on on shipping
the minimum viable change
and finally on transparency
so the first iteration of the plan was
really a combination
of a really boring solution and a
minimum viable plan
so we considered whether we could just
stop the whole site
copy all the data from azure to gcp
and then switch the dns over to pointed
gcp and then start everything up again
so the problem is that we had too much
data
to do this within a reasonable time
frame so we had at the time about half a
petabyte
in total of data on azure and once we'd
shut down the site we'd need to copy all
of this data
between two cloud providers over the
internet and then once the copy was
complete
we'd need to verify the data and make
sure that it was all 100
correct and only then could we start the
site up again
this plan meant that gitlab.com could be
down for several days on end
and considering that thousands and
thousands of people rely on gitlab on a
daily basis
this didn't really work so we went back
to the drawing board
and started considering what our options
would be
so around about the same time we were
working on
another feature at gitlab and that's
called geo
and what jio allowed us to do is develop
a feature for our enterprise customers
so that they could replicate a gitlab
instance
from one site to another and this is
really useful because you can use it for
faster access at the second site
it's also redundancy and you can use it
for offsite disaster recovery
so geo works by doing an initial
synchronization
of all of your data from the first site
to the second site
and then afterwards it makes sure that
everything is
is synchronized so that any change on
the first site is
is replicated to the second in near real
time so you always have a duplicate copy
of your data
now gitlab.com is not a fork of of
gitlab gitlab.com
is gitlab and so brandon mentioned that
on the 22nd of every month
we do a release of get lab and the first
place that that release
is deployed to is gitlab.com on the
seventh of the month so
two weeks before we we released the
software
we deploy it on our own servers on
gitlab.com and we even use the same
package installer called git lab omnibus
to to install onto gitlab.com and this
means that any feature
that we build for our self-managed
customers is also available for us to
use on gitlab.com
and so we hope that by utilizing these
replication capabilities that we were
building for geo
we could migrate the entire gitlab.com
site from uh to a secondary instance
in in gcp
so a new plan was formed using geo4
replication
and the secondary environment would be
gcp as i mentioned and then what we do
is synchronize
all the data and this could possibly
take weeks or it could take months
it didn't really matter because the site
would be available throughout the
synchronization process
and then once all the data had been
synchronized from
uh to to gcp we could
verify it and make sure that it was all
100 correct
and then we could just promote the gcp
environment as
uh and make it our new primary this had
many advantages over
the the initial plan so obviously
firstly gitlab.com would be up
for the uh for the for the
synchronization and then
we would have a period of down time but
it would be very short maybe an hour or
two
and the other thing that was great about
it is we could time box it so
we could know exactly how long that that
down time was going to be
um then since the new environment we're
running all of our production data we
could we could verify it we could do
qa we could build automated qa tools
manual qa tools we could do load testing
on it and obviously we could verify
all of the data before before the
failover and then finally
because we had this migration it would
we could use the migration as an
opportunity to do ultimate qa of of
gitlab
of gitlab geo and so basically if it
could work for us
on gitlab.com it would pretty much work
for any other customer who wants to use
jira
and we could be confident in that um
that goes back to the iteration and the
testing
and that goes back to our value of
iteration testing dog fooding
we make sure before our customers touch
it we're going to make sure we runs
great
and then it gets into the largest
deployment in the world which means
if you're running it yourself you can be
fully confident that that's something
that's ready to go
cool so around about this time we were
actually working on another
major project and that was called cloud
native gitlab
and this project is basically about
building a set of helm charts for gitlab
so that we could deploy gitlab inside a
kubernetes environment
and much like omnibus is our official
package installer for
for installing gitlab outside a
kubernetes environment
omni uh the helm charts in cloud native
git lab is our official installer for
installing
uh gitlab inside a kubernetes
environment
so instead of provisioning the the new
environment using chef and
and omnibus we thought maybe what we
could do is deploy it
into kubernetes using uh google
kubernetes engine
and our hum charts and so we evolved the
plan with another iteration
so that we use cloud native for uh for
setting up the new environment
the problem was that this approach um
it became apparent that there were
problems with this approach as we went
along
so the changes that we needed to make to
gitlab.com at least to gitlab the
product
were extensive and and we realized that
there was going to be some major rework
and so it was difficult to align the
time frames of the cloud native gitlab
project and the gcp migration
in order to get them both delivered
within the time frames that we wanted
so we went back and we we sort of went
to the next iteration
where we where we went back to using
omnibus for
our for provisioning the new environment
but we also realized that it would be
worthwhile to migrate as much
data as possible to object storage with
google cloud storage
and so obviously a lot of the data on on
gitlab
is is git data but there's also huge
amounts of non-git data sort of build
artifacts
ci repositories rci images
that sort of thing and what we could do
is take it off
nfs where it restored and move it into
object storage
and doing this would allow us to reduce
the risk and the scale of the geo
migration
um and additionally moving that data
into object storage and
and eliminating nfs from our stack meant
that
in future when we moved to kubernetes um
it would be much easier
because we didn't have to worry about
nfs
so the steps for the migration were now
fairly straightforward
we would provision a new environment in
with gitlab omnibus
and we would set it up as a jio
secondary in in gcp
and then we'd replicate all the data
from gitlab.com in azure
to tcp uh we'd wait for the initial
synchronization to complete
and then while when it had completed
we'd test the new environment with
automated manual
testing tools and we'd obviously verify
that all the data is
100 correct and then finally once that's
done
we'd fail over to the gcp environment
promote it to primary
and we'd be done
so obviously
so we began to set up the new
environment and we started the
replication process
um and started replicating non-git
content to object storage
now being remote means that we can't
spend our time playing sword fights in
the hallways while we wait for things
so we used the time to be productive
and we started implementing other
features in our new environment so we
set up identity aware proxies
uh for all of our internal web apps we
set up cloud key management service
for security and we also did a major
revamp of our logging infrastructure
moving to structured logging wherever we
could um and switching to fluentd
and google pub sub for for logging
and for short term logging we use
stackdriver and elk
and for long term logging we stored our
data in google cloud storage
so there was only one major unknown left
in this plan
and that was the actual failover
operation itself
so unfortunately geo at the time didn't
support a failover operation
so nobody knew exactly how we would go
about doing that so we needed to define
a step-by-step plan to carry out this
failover
now considering the stakes were so high
it was essential that we got this right
the first time that we tried it and how
did we ensure this well
we just kept on iterating so
we set up a failover procedure as an
issue template in gitlab
uh and then each step in the in the fair
level was a checklist item
and then we started practicing the
failover and every time we created uh
we did a practice we'd create a new
issue from the template we'd run through
it
and anything that went wrong would get
fed back into the
into the template as a merge request so
the whole team would have a say
and we could discuss it on a merge
request and and through this very tight
feedback loop
we could like rapidly improve the um
the the failover procedure
so this this animation over here shows
the main failover documents
um and there were over 140 changes in
that document
um so every time we tried something we
would submit a change
and over time the document got longer
and longer and longer
and the entire when we started every
time we tried it
it would basically not work but every
time we tried
every time we did it we'd improve it a
little and we kept doing this
until we were totally confident that the
failover would work
and then when we were confident we
actually introduced another level of
difficulty
by starting to mess with the failover
having somebody
secretly shutting down servers or
rebooting redis or shutting down a
postgas primary
and then the team would have to
recognize it that it happened and
take uh take it into account detect it
and and improve it and then carry on
with the failover and once we were doing
that
we knew that we were totally confident
and then it was time to
to carry out the failover so we let
google know
and they assembled an amazing team to to
help us with the
with this with the failover sorry just
grab some
one fun note on that uh previous slide
if you're ever interested in exactly how
that works
it's an open issue so anyone that's
interested you can watch exactly how we
cut it over
you can go look on exactly how we went
through that process
and so you're going to know detail by
detail ad nauseum
what that kind of work takes so if it's
something you all are trying to solve
again we put all our documents out there
because we want to collaborate and help
everyone else along the same journey
we've been and obviously get your
feedback
um not necessarily on the cutover that's
long been since done
but in the rest of what we do so matters
an enormous amount to us hopefully that
becomes something also
that's a usable document and i think
pretty unusual that a company is
live stream how they make the migration
as well as giving everyone else
visibility on how you might be able to
do it yourself
cool oh sorry
so i skipped a little bit further so we
google assembled an amazing team of
people to support us on the day
um and and we knew they'd be available
if we needed any assistance
luckily the failover went really
smoothly and we didn't experience any
major problems
on the monday following over uh
following on the failover following the
failover
as traffic started rising on the site we
started seeing some performance issues
and working with google we realized that
our gitly servers which run all the kits
operations for for get lab
were we're struggling a little bit and
we we spoke to google
uh we we they suggested we move from
uh n1 uh high mem uh
8 machines to n1 standard 32 machines
and so we rotated the fleet out to those
and after that it was
plain sailing the whole way
so going back to the goals of the
project did we make
gitlab.com suitable for mission critical
workloads so firstly let's
consider availability on gitlab.com
and so as an external tool we use
pingdom to monitor the site externally
and tell us if
if it sees any failures and so i pulled
the data from from pingdom from
before when we were in azure and then
afterwards when we're in gcp
and this is a graph of the number of
errors we saw
per day in those two environments
so that is a few months before and that
is
everything after the failover and the
blue background i'm colorblind i can't
see it being blue in this
in this image but hopefully it is the
blue background is the period when we
were running in in gcp
so prior to our failover we had about
8.2
uh pingdom errors a day and after the
failover
we had just one error a day
so uh pingdom also reports availability
and uh this you can see is our
availability in the year leading up to
the migration
it's 99.61
and afterwards was 99.93 now some people
might think that those two numbers are
are really similar
but they're not 99.61 is 39 minutes of
down time a week
and afterwards we've seen seven minutes
of downtime so we still have some
improvements to make
but it's a lot better than it was
so the the other way that we can compare
the site is
is with the performance of gitlab.com
before and after
moving to azure so one way that we can
do this is with latency histogram
uh which shows us the performance of of
requests to get lab
and what i did for this was i took data
for one week before the migration
and one week after the migration so that
there weren't too many other changes to
the application we were
pretty much comparing like with like um
and what you can see
is that the uh the gcp line
drops off much quicker and has a much
much sort of
lower tail of values and so what this
shows us is that our gitlab
instance in azure was was slower and our
gitlab instance in gcp was much faster
and we also had far fewer
sort of unpredictable values so so
random values that took 30
seconds or random requests that took 30
seconds
um and then finally we have like as
brandon said we have all the documents
we have
the issue tracker we have the project
documentation
all available over here for everyone to
to take a look at
[Music]
you